[Music]
[Music]
okay oh there's some bees in pop allows
you to be the voice for the voices when
I met Isaiah I didn't know what to
expect once had an opportunity to
communicate with him I was like now he
can he can talk he can talk he has no
problem talking let's figure out how in
the song when I think of Isaiah as an
artist or more so feel that he's a poet
he's writing poetry he's talking about
his experiences I don't care what people
think of me Friday night they carry me
jump going but I've done myself like a
liner to my family my first record that
Isaiah I did was oxygen to fly he wrote
it I was the voice it's a challenge to
be someone else's voice but Isaiah has
so many things that he wants to say we
find a way to make it work haha yeah
yeah okay wouldn't it next with your we
could work on the second verse before I
worked with Isaiah I had a heavy
presence in the local scene as far as
rap music as well there's some community
work alright we're going from the top
okay we were able to come together and
kind of amplify our message and that's
just that you shouldn't stand to the
side and do nothing if you're fully
capable of doing something I brought out
a special guest tonight
[Music]
[Music]
in a different mall candy on the road
had to do some different things with the
family all
[Music]